yeah i think but i think it's because
when i go on the road like i just went
to bakersfield recently which is
can we just say it's like the best
people ever came out
feels [ __ ] amazing oh dude right i
felt like i
i felt like hulk hogan broke people came
out people were crying
someone sacrificed their cousin some guy
came out of the closet like oh
wow they wanted it all to happen at the
show you know
people were giving me recipes people
were donating no here's the thing man it
ain't that far
hour and forty minutes how long does it
take from l.a two hours two hours max
pretty diverse i i mean yeah it was cool
man i really liked it
although i did turn my sink on it's
brown [ __ ] was [ __ ] flying out of the
sink i was like what
the [ __ ] is made a shout out instagram
video of it
yeah i was like bakersfield what the
[ __ ] is going on with your water man
this ain't good
look at that that's my water coming out
of my [ __ ] sink
and the worst is you already brushed
your teeth that's the crazy part too i
hate it when that happens because you
don't know it first
oh it's so funky definitely seems like a
malt
but i think that i was staying at our
super old hotel
yeah yeah but it's just they they got
some old ass pipes
clean those pipes son yeah something's
going wrong there i was staying there so
get in there yeah
what if what if i took a mouthful of
that drank it like
what if he died what if i was just
[ __ ] all over myself for the rest of
the day and how to cancel my shows
dude do you think you'll die one day or
not i'm not trying to make you think
about it
um i'm pretty sure that's how the road
goes
yeah you're born and then you die why
what do you think
i don't know man crusher doesn't think
you die i think i think he's just drunk
yeah that could be it too yeah and you
don't have a shirt on dude you have to
put a shirt on and decide if you're
gonna die or not
he goes prove it prove it
oh boy we have to base this on what we
know about people now i know that people
used to be alive and now they're not
so what happened to them are they faking
it
will you be sad if you die you think i
think i'll be dead bro
yeah what about you i'd be sad if you
died
oh thank you i'd be sad if you died too
thanks man prove it